bon c'est evian n'a pas publié
uniquement des excuses ils ont clarifié
le tweet initial d'après sur la question
de dire ça elle puisque ça le débat
c'est déjà le cas des musulmans qui ont
qui sont pas d'accord parce que en
premier le premier jour du ramadan ils
ont fait ça comme une provocation
oui moi je les ai vus sept tweets il m'a
pas choqué j'ai pas eu plus soif par ce
que j'ai vu ce tweet d'accord j'ai pas
pu souffert du ramadan parce qu'il vient
à poster ça et même quand on cherche les
réactions à cette fuite
on trouve pas tant de réactions que
c'est pourquoi evian a pris peur et et
vion ils se sont excusés ils ont ces
incroyables eric naulleau moi je suis
chez moi j'ai cru que c'était un poisson
d'avril
vraiment je n'y ai pas cru et pourtant
c'est une vraie polémique non et vision
a commis une grosse erreur
une seule grosse erreur c'est de
s'excuser il n'avait pas à s'excuser il
ont fait leur travail
le boulot déviance et de vendre de
l'evian sans se préoccuper du calendrier
musulman du calendrier chrétien du
calendrier bouddhistes et même du
calendrier at et le problème c'est que
dans les détracteurs des dire moi je
pense que 99% vers une 9 % des musulmans
s'en foutent
mais il ya une petite minorité active
qui est une minorité islamistes et qui
profitent de chaque occasion même des
occasions aussi bizarre que ça pour
essayer de faire avancer la cause
islamiste à dire de faire de maître la
loi islamiste au dessus de la loi de la
république donc ce sont des activistes
qui provoque septime agitation de
rêveries de regarder parce qu'il ya de
gilles verdez et guillaume genton qui
eux pensent qu'elle vient a bien fait de
s'excuser pourquoi gilles ce café evian
c'est scandaleux moi je vais vous dire
lequel le premier tweet premier tweet
verte et munication d'evian pour moi je
veux croire ya un mot fort c'est de
l'islamophobie commercial c'est-à-dire
que vous faites exprès de taper de
provoquer de taper sur les musulmans
vous ils ont fait ça si elles savent
très bien c'est sciemment et ils se
foutent du bad buzz parce que c'est du
buzz
donc il se dit on y va à bout monta
premier jour du ramadan faut pas les
prendre pour des gens stupides evian
c'est d'annoncer un grand groupe
ils savent très bien ce qu'ils font ils
tapent sur les musulmans et il voit que
ça suscite une polémique donc il
s'excuse ils sont obligé de s'excuser
mais c'est scandaleux de faire ça c'est
pas du tout islamisés sur le ramadan
vous avant le tomber des nues et c'est
dramatique ce que tu me nationale
ces propos comme ça qu'on combat une
famine lancée on ne fait plus créer une
scission encourager les noms oui oui
c'est pas moi c'est non non je crois pas
d'une ampleur mec j'ai vu à la pub qui
dit on va faire une pub pour beaurains
les dodos par jour parce que c'est le
lot de profiteurs du ramadan c'est un
peu c'est vous rigolez géraldine maillet
et gilles verdez pardon mais je trouve
que tu es fou furieux
ça a été et est vraiment un danger
public c'est bien mais ça fait une
polémique la génération aujourd'hui des
au fond c'est des indignés qui tombe
dans le sort de tourbillon comme ça à
bixi mer c'est dramatique donc juste je
vais te dire sur france 5 à midi on nous
apprenait à faire une soupe de maïs
provoque islamophobie hockey à 12h15 y
avait une plume pour la publicité
une publicité pardon pour la console de
fruits est-ce que c'est da provoque
aujourd'hui sur m6 ça n'a rien à voir il
faut aller à saint gilles verdez non
mais là non là c'est de la publicité
classique là comme par hasard vous avez
déjà bu un litre le déjà si vous avez
déjà lu puisque c'est aujourd'hui
arrêter ses volontés très gras fait eric
naulleau parce que d'abord il se
comporte en idiot utile de l'islamisme
et rx 8
non mais ne riez pas mon nom et la
balance avec les filles on fait tous les
jours des tweets choix même si je finis
jean thermale il relève le tweet
aujourd'hui mais tous les jours moi qui
ai une maison à evian je peux vous dire
que tous les ans d'après un truc tous
les jours une petite elle allonge il ya
des trucs sur les eaux thermales et les
photos verdez aggrave le sentiment de
persécution des musulmans pour un motif
en plus imaginaires c'est déjà assez
tendue en ce moment il ya des polémiques
régulière il ya parfois des polémiques
sur des bases réelles
là c'est une base complètement
imaginaire et il ya des gens qui vont
prendre au sérieux sur une
responsabilité et tu sors des énormités
pareilles n'est pas une généralité
concours à la discorde nationale et même
un jour à la guerre civile ne raconte
pas n'importe quoi essaye d'utiliser des
arguments qu'on puisse croire là je
crois même pas ce que tu dis et je crois
que même pas que toi tu crois que tu ici
on